الشيء الوحيد الذي
لا يريده الرياضي أبدًا هو أن يكون ضعيفًا بالطبع ،
فهم جميعًا بشر ، لكن من
المهم جدًا إبراز شخصية لا يمكن اختراقها
في مجال اللعب ، لكن
أحد أفضل نجوم الرجبي في العالم يقول هذا
أن كونك ضعيفًا لديه  ساعده في أن
يصبح لاعبًا أفضل ،
إنه فقط بيل ويليامز اعتنق
الإسلام قبل 10 سنوات وأصبح أول
مسلم يلعب لفريق All Blacks
وكان جزءًا رئيسيًا من أعظم
فترة نجاح لهم بالفوز
بكأس العالم مرتين متتاليتين في 2011 و  ثم في عام 2015
، تحظى فرقة All Blacks بالتبجيل في نيوزيلندا ،
لكن البلاد كانت ممتنة بشكل خاص
لقيادة ويليامز في أعقاب
هجوم المسجد هذا العام الذي خلف
أكثر من 50 قتيلاً ، وكان سوني بيل
ويليامز يتحدث مع أليكس
توماس حول العقيدة التي جعلته.  مجانًا
عندما يتعلق الأمر باللاعبين أو الرياضيين الذين
يؤدون عروضهم في الثلاثينيات من عمرهم ،
فهم لا يفعلون ذلك في جميع أنحاء العالم
هذه الأيام التي تعلم فيها أن هناك
تقدمًا في علم الرياضة و
ماذا وكيف تأكل وأنت
تعرف بنفسي أنني مسلم لمدة 10
سنوات على مدى 10 سنوات ، وهو مجرد
حياة نظيفة ونظيفة ، كما تعلم ، تساعدني حقًا في
أن أظل على ما أعتقد في الجزء العلوي من
لعبتي هل قمت بذلك  كان خيار
التحول إلى رجل أفضل أو أن
تصبح رياضيًا أفضل
تتوق روحي لشيء ما ولم أكن
أعرف ما كان ذلك كنت صغيرًا كنت أعتقد أن
كل ما أعرفه كان بالكامل وكل ما
أعرفه هو أن أكون على حق  في معتقداتي أو في
تلك اللعبة في الواقع حددت من كنت إذا
لعبت مباراة جيدة ثم شعرت أنني كنت
شخصًا جيدًا إذا لعبت لعبة سيئة ،
فلن أرغب في مغادرة المنزل
وأعتقد أن هذا هو ما لدى الإسلام
أعطاني ، لقد سمح لي أن أكون ضعيفًا
بما يكفي للدخول في بعض
المواقف المعينة ، والخطيئة
والقيادة والازدهار وأضع نفسي هناك ، كل
أولئك الذين تم إضافتهم على طول
الرحلة التي هي الرياضة ، وهي
الرياضة ، إنها قطار الملاهي صعودا وهبوطا
أنا كل هذه الدروس
جعلتني بالتأكيد  الرجل الذي أنا عليه اليوم إذا لم
تصبح مسلمًا ، هل تعتقد
أنك ما زلت ستحقق ما حققته
في مجال الرياضة ، وأنا أعلم
أنك أصبحت أيضًا شخصية مسلمة
أيضًا.
فكر في أنك تعتنق ذلك ، بالتأكيد أعتقد أنه بمرور الوقت
أصبحت أكثر ثقة في الشخص
الذي أعتقد أنه الرجل في مجتمع اليوم ،
لقد تعلمنا تقريبًا أن نكون
محرجين من الإسلام لنكون
محرجين بسبب القليل من السوء
أعتقد أن
الكثير من الدول الغربية لديها
فكرة خاطئة عن الإسلام ، أنت تعلم أنني
لست سياسيًا ولكني أفعل ذلك فقط وأحاول
عدم الخوض في أشياء لا
أعرف الكثير عنها حقًا ولكنني أتت  قريبًا جدًا من
المنزل ، أليس كذلك مع كرايستشيرش
بنسبة مائة بالمائة والعودة إلى الوراء كما
قلت إنني لا أحب الخوض في المجالات
التي لا أعرف الكثير عنها ولكن في
ذلك الوقت كنت نيوزيلندا ألعب
بن في نيوزيلندا  ربما يكون
أحد أكثر المسلمين شهرة
لكون البلد أسود بالكامل وأنا أعلم أنني
كسرت وجهي العملة
المعدنية وكنت أؤذيك أعلم أنني أعلم أن
النيوزيلنديين كانوا يؤذون الأذى الذي يلحق بالمسلمين
، لذلك كان علي أن أقوم بالتقدم وكان علي
أن أعلمك بالدخول إلى تلك المساحة  وأن أكون
ضعيفًا وأنت تعلم أحيانًا أنني
لم أكن أعرف ما كنت أفعله ، لكنني كنت
أعرف أنني كنت أحاول أن أكون إيجابيًا ،
أعتقد أننا كنيوزيلنديين قادنا حقًا
الطريق في تلك المساحة في الحديث
عن الفيل في  الغرفة ، ما الذي فعلته
بالطريقة التي
يتعامل بها رئيس وزراء بلدك مع الأمر
في ذلك الوقت ، كان الأمر
مميزًا ، أرفع قبعتي لها وأعتقد أنك تعلم أنني
آمل فقط أن تستمر تلك المحادثات
في الحدوث.
ليس فقط من
أجل المجتمع المسلم ، فكل ما تعرفه
الأقليات التي تكافح من أجل
مواجهة العنصرية بشكل أفضل لأنك تعلم أنها
مشكلة كبيرة في العالم اليوم وكما
قلت أنا لست سياسيًا ولكني فقط
أحاول وأفعل  ما أشعر به هو الحق وأعتقد
أنا ممتن ومبارك لأن الرياضة
سمحت لي باستخدام تلك السيارة لدفع
المزيد من الإيجابية إلى
العالم.